Okay guys, so in this video, we are going to learn about fair value gaps and imbalances.
They are the same thing, but different names.
You could either call it fair value gap or imbalance, it's really up to you, but a shout
out to this guy over here, great presentation or diagram, you could say.
Okay, so a gap of liquidity left during the movedown and trials due to new brain pressure
overlapping that part of the move in the previous or next scandal.
So basically, what is fair value gap?
Is the space between the three candles, all right, so this is the one candle, second candle
and third candle.
So as you can see from the left side, from this low and the third candle to the right,
this high, there's this gap, all right, there's nothing around this level, all right.
So this is considered to be imbalance.
I will repeat, you can see that price went up and then we had three candles, okay, so
this is like a three candle, um, pattern, you could say.
So you can see one, two, three, three candles.
And in between those three candles, there should be a gap, okay, so how do we determine
a gap?
We look, if we are looking at a short position, we're going to look from the, we're going
to look, start looking from the first candle.
So this is the first candle and we look at the low of the first candle, which is this.
And then we look at the high of the third candle.
And if there is gap between the low of the first candle and the high of the third candle,
then that area could be considered as fair value gap or imbalance.
Now why does this happen is when big institutional buyers or sellers are in the market.
When there is unfair, or you could say huge amounts of selling or buying going on, market
leaves unfair price, okay, and that price should always be filled.
It should be filled to keep the value of the market fair, if that makes sense.
So that is why we call it a fair value gap, because when price comes into this level,
it, it makes a price fair, if that makes sense, all right.
So if we look at the by example here, we look for the high of the first candle and the low
of the third candle.
So this is again, a three candle formation, remember that one, two, three, all right.
So the first candle, we're looking at a by example, okay.
So the first candle, the high of the first candle and the low of the third candle, we
have to look for these two things, all right, the high of the first candle and the low of
the third candle.
If there's any space between the first candle and the third candle, then that space should
be considered as fair value gap, all right.
So let me give you some examples.
So as you can see, we got, let me zoom in a bit.
You can see one, two, three candles, right.
So we're looking at three candles, okay.
So we got one candle right here, the second candle right here and the third candle right
around here, all right.
And in between these three candles, we got fair value gap, all right.
So let me put that like this and let me go to the repo mode.
So it's clear for you guys, all right, okay.
So as you can see, what we discussed, when we're looking for a short position, we are
going to look for the low of the first candle, which is this, as you can see, there is a
week, right.
So this is the low of the first candle.
And then we look at the high of the third candle.
And there you can see there's gap around this level, right.
And what we should be expecting is that price is going to fill this level, this imbalance
and go down, all right.
So let's see what happens.
Price fills the imbalance and then it drops down.
Very simple guys, okay.
And as you can see, price goes up a bit, fills all the imbalance here.
And there should be some imbalance on a smaller timeframe, all right.
So we are looking at this imbalance on a five minute timeframe.
But I'm pretty sure there's going to be imbalance on a short timeframe.
So let's go to the one minute timeframe.
And as you can see, as you can see, if we zoom in, you can see there's gap, all right,
from here to here.
So a one, two, three candles, very nice.
And then you can see we got this gap, all right, and price must fill this level.
So if we draw this out, you can see how perfectly price filled the imbalance here, make the
price fair, and then it went down all the way down, all right.
So let me play this out for you.
Yep.
So it went all the way down.
Let me give you an example for by position.
All right.
So we are looking at this, all right.
So we got, let me label it so it's easier for you.
Okay.
So we got the one candle around here, whoops, all right.
So this is our first candle.
Okay, I should just, so this is first candle, right?
This second, and this is third.
When we're looking for buys, we are going to look at the high, the very high of the
first candle and the low of the third candle.
And then we wait for the price to fill this level.
And as you can see, if we draw this out, price filled this level, fill this imbalance or
fill the value gap, and it went all the way up, all right.
And I'm pretty sure that there was some imbalance around this level here as well, all right,
on a 30 second timeframe or, I don't know, 15 second timeframe.
Remember guys, price is fractal, all right.
So whatever is happening on the one made, it could be happening on a smaller timeframe.
So it doesn't really matter what timeframe you're looking at as long as you are following
your rules.
Okay, so as you can see, price fills the imbalance and the fair value gap, and it just
goes all the way up.
Now we should not use the fair value gap or imbalance, whatever you want to call it, as
an independent strategy, all right.
This is something that we're going to use with a lot of other confluences like liquidity,
market structure break, okay, market structure shift and all.
So keep watching.
And I'm pretty sure that you should be pretty clear about imbalances and what they are.
I tried my best, my very best to explain it to you.
I really do hope that you understood it.
If you did not, I would highly recommend that you watch this video again because this is
one of the most important things of this course.
So yeah, I'll see you guys in the next video.